عاشروا ايام الحرب بين البرهان وحميتي
تزايد مستمر في اعداد الضحايا والمصابين
تقابله عمليات نزوح من العاصمه الخرطوم
واجلاء للبعثات الدبلوماسيه ورعايا عده
دول في الحصيله الاخيره لضحايا هذا النزاع
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان عن ارتفاع عدد
القتلى المدنيين الى 273 فضلا عن تسجيل
نحو 1600 حاله اصابه بين المدنيين منذ
اندلاع الاشتباكات في الخامس عشر من ابريل
الجاري واشارت النقابه الى ان 69% من
المستشفيات متوقفه عن الخدمه حيث انه من
اصل 79 مستشفى في العاصمه 55 مستشفى توقفت
عن الخدمه وحوالي 13 مستشفى تم قصفها
وتسعى عشره مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء القصري
نتيجه للوضع الامني في البلاد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات